salut c'est le bal pour but les gens
normaux se sent bien dans la machine
dans magna jamais trouvé sa place elle
marcher nu en criant des mots magiques
ils disent qu'elle était folle semble
screamo la folie vaut la folie
jeanine ces masses ma grand-mère du coup
c'est la mère de ma mère et elle elle
s'appelait jeanine pendant la première
partie de sa vie et puis ensuite dans
les années 70 elle a divorcé et elle a
commencé à voyager à rencontrer les gens
et c'était un peu le la libération de la
femme aussi à cette époque que tout le
monde envoie et du coup elle a rencontré
des gens des communautés un peu
spirituel à chaud à la changer de nom
c'est appeler amina
à partir de là puis elle a mené une
autre ville est très différente elle a
fait le tour du monde elle est partie
dans des projets très humanitaire très
humaniste au fait plus que monétaire
puisque c'était même elle faisait ça
tout seul avec un rêve quoi de elle
voulait sauver le monde par la
nourriture c'est ça qu'elle disait donc
elle est partie en inde à l armée les
marchés les trucs pour essayer de faire
des de récupérer tout ce qui pouvait
calé le gaspiller en faire d énormes
repas faire l'objet tout le monde et
c'est donc c'était c'est quelque chose
c'est sûr je suis assez fier de date
spécifique pour ce genre de chose à quoi
voit la folie c'est une phrase que
que je me suis mis à dire en concert
pendant la tournée de flip quand je
jouais lui si j'avais envie de jeu
remettait le refrain pour parce que le
refrain et passe vite et qu'il est
qu'une fois dans le morceau donc c'était
assez logique de leur mettre une
deuxième fois et du coup je voulais
chauffer les gens et les rend fous donc
je leur disais c'est beau quand vous
lâcher ses mots quand vous êtes fous et
en fait après je me mettais à dire c'est
beau la folie et journée ça puis je sais
pas pourquoi je disais aux gens rappelez
vous de cette phrase est touchée elle
mais elle avait un impact fort sciemment
je le sentais bien quoi et après quand
j'ai commencé à écrire jeanine bas je me
suis dit c'est s est elle assez logique
de reprendre cette phrase qu'on va faire
un morceau
après quand j'ai reçu l'instru de mav le
le thème sur ma famille sur ma grand
mère etc a commencé à arriver un petit
peu sur l'album et je me suis ouais j'ai
voulu parler de de certains aspects de
la folie qui peuvent être beau surtout
quand c'est comme ça parle de liberté
et puis c'est un peu pour reprendre tout
ce truc assez cliché mais devra de de
dire qu'il ya c'est qu'une question de
point de vue quand la folie et que pour
pour certaines personnes c'est nous qui
sommes malades quoi c'est notre société
qui est malade ce que je lis ans et là
c'est la liberté quoi le ça que je
trouve beau il ya plein de choses qui
sont pas belles parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de souffrance mais il ya aussi ce truc
de pas vouloir s'adapter à un monde dans
lequel on vit quoi qui est quand même
imposé qui peut être sacrément bizarre
si on regarde un satané quoi je voulais
pas faire de couplet sur ma famille
parce que je trouvais ça trop
storytelling et puis j'avais comme
j'avais envie de rester mystérieux de
toute façon je pouvais pas me permettre
de donner plus de détails et du coup je
me suis dit le thème du morceau c'est
beau la folie c'est même si je parle de
ma grand-mère dans le refrain c'est ça
le thème des morceaux c'est la folie en
général et donc du coup je faisais le
premier couplet sur ma famille et
deuxième couplet je le faisais sur sur
une histoire fictive avec une fille quoi
vous me dire que j'ai toujours été un
peu attiré par sa aussi quoi toujours
été attiré un peu par une fille qui
pourrait me surprendre qui pourrait tout
d'un coup même la spontanéité la folie
de faire un peu tout d'une seconde à
l'autre mais ça se ressent dans plein
d'autres morceaux quand je
on pourra partir et avec le premier
avion un truc comme un film de merde
mais cdc que des références de tout d'un
coup c'est ça la liberté quoi c'est de
voir ce que tu veux quand tu veux
et des fois les gens fous ils permettent
de le faire c'est sûr si tout le monde
faisait ça on s'en sortirait pas mais on
est obligé de reconnaître c'est quelque
chose d'assez beau et poétique dans le
fait d'être libéré de toutes les chaînes
du système moi c'est moi c'est ce qui me
fait rêver mais c'est subjectif après
moi ce qui me fait rêver mais toutes les
formes d'amour et existe quoi je me sens
assez sain d'esprit quand même c'est pas
ce que ça veut dire mais je ne
m'inquiète pas pour ça j'ai pris peur
quand j'étais petit devenir fou mais
aujourd'hui j'ai plus peur de ça je
crois